ce smartphone est très chouette pourquoi
parce que vous avez un petit écran à
l'extérieur qui vous permet de venir
faire pas mal de choses et ça c'est cool
c'est le oppo finden de flip on va
pouvoir venir prendre des photos mode
portrait vidéo très facilement vous vous
voyez c'est très clair très net vous
posez votre main ça déclenche une photo
c'est très pratique hey mode portrait
vidéo également on va pouvoir avoir
accès à sa météo à son agenda une
minuterie un enregistreur la commande de
vous écouteurs va arriver la dictée
vocale mais également Spotify vous avez
un grand écran à l'intérieur de 6,8
pouces avec surtout une pliure qui se
sent quasiment pas sous le doigt et si
on vient comparer par rapport aux zip de
Samsung ça se sent deux fois moins tout
en ayant d'écran extérieur deux fois
plus grand vous avez un capteur
principal de 50 mégapixels plus un ultra
grand angle de 8 mégapixels sans oublier
un bloc de charge de 67 watts inclus
même si si vous rechargez uniquement 44
watts bon c'est pas très grave on a
beaucoup de performances avec le
processeur de médiathèque le dîner City
plus 10 Go c'est un smartphone qui est
très cool qui est très atypique qui
vient surtout se plier moi je trouve
très chouette c'est le oppo finden de
flip dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires ce qu'il
vous intéresse oui non quoi comment
marquer moi